[DRAMATIC MUSIC]
What's up, everybody?
I'm Langston Belton.
And I am joined by the
cast and creative team
of Marvel Studios' Loki.
Hello, everyone.
All right, let's get into it.
So at the end of episode
one, we find out that there
are multiple Lokis out there.
So, Tom, what was
it like approaching
this role with that knowledge?
Well, you know, we contain
multitudes, as the saying goes.
I found there's so many
multifaceted aspects
of his character,
which often exist
within him, either in
concert or in conflict.
And that's part of the
pleasure I have in playing him.
And then to have the interior
multiplicity externalized
was thrilling.
Ah.
So for the rest of
you, what was it
like building a brand-new series
around a character like Loki
that the fans already
know and love?
Tom is a Loki encyclopedia.
And we kind of came
up with this idea,
and I was like, we
should do Loki school.
And he basically like spoke
to all my heads of department
and did, like, a Loki lecture.
Meeting with him, and
him kind of walking me
through over the course
of a few days, kind
of the whole mythology and
explaining his character
and letting me kind
of ask questions.
And I think that stuff really
helped within our dynamic
once we started filming.
Now there are some amazing
new characters in this series,
as well.
Can you please tell us a little
bit about your characters?
My character-- she is
a hunter, Hunter B-15.
And she works for the TVA.
She's pretty rigid.
[LAUGHS] She's a little cheeky,
too, and a little salty.
I play Ravonna Renslayer,
who is a judge in the TVA.
She's worked her way up.
She had a history as a
hunter, a more military role,
like Wunmi's character.
And she came up from that to
be sort of one of the most
powerful judges in the
TVA who reports directly
to the Time-Keepers,
who are sort
of the all-seeing
overlords of time.
Oh, nice And, Owen,
your character, Mobius,
goes out of his way to
enlist the help of Loki.
So what's on Mobius's mind?
Well, you know,
nothing much, just
the fate of the whole universe.
Uh-- [LAUGHS]
Let's talk about
the whole universe.
If there are variant
versions of all of you
out there across
various timelines,
what do you think
they're up to right now?
[LAUGHS] Oh, my gosh.
I don't know.
Variant versions of me.
There are.
And some are, you know, some
are very quiet and well-behaved,
and some are more mischievous.
I suppose there's a version
of me in some alternate reality
who didn't get cast as Loki.
A teacher?
Is he a gardener?
No.
I'd be a terrible gardener.
I just don't have it in the DNA.
There's probably ballet
Gugu and painter Gugu.
Oh, an archaeologist.
Or a volcanic researcher.
Those are all things I wanted
to do when I was a kid.
In episode one, we get a
tour of the incredible TVA
headquarters.
What was it like creating a
brand-new location for the MCU?
I think, for me,
the exciting thing
in creating the TVA is this
organization that exists
outside of space and time.
So it's kind of like
Vegas in a way that--
it's not on a planet.
There's no sun.
It's in this unknowable
kind of place.
And the comic books have
these amazing images of, like,
these desks stretching
off into infinity, which
is definitely something
we took to our designer
and were inspired by.
We had to define
what that power set is.
There were certainly just
a lot of time travel rule
defining that we had to do.
But ultimately, very exciting to
take the most powerful arguably
magical organization that
you could possibly conceive,
and then make them as
boring as possible.
Just purely
bureaucratic paperwork.
Well, some people
find paperwork exciting.
To each their own, right?
Well, all right.
I'm sorry.
I got to put you on the spot.
What are you most excited for
fans to see in this series?
I mean, the whole thing.
It's a whole new world.
And it just opens you
up to different ideas,
and about good and bad,
and right and wrong,
and hero villain.
I am most excited for fans to
see what happens to Loki when
he has nowhere left to run.
And he can't delude
himself anymore.
And I'll stop talking,
otherwise I'll say too much.
Well, we are all very
excited to see what comes next.
Thank you all so
much for joining me.
And all of you out there, don't
miss Marvel Studios' Loki,
with new episodes
streaming every Wednesday
exclusively on Disney+.